be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so absolute carnage just keeps
getting better and better
this story just keeps getting
ridiculously good it's absolutely insane
and what this one does is it gives us
like one of the coolest moments ever in
the history of venom and and all that
good stuff now initially this picks up
after issue number two I'm still
debating on whether or not I'm gonna
cover the tie-ins I'm not 100% sure
that's one of the reasons why I'm doing
this issue by issue is because if we
decide to cover the tie-ins we can do
that later on just by like you know or
at least actually done like covering
that video and then throwing into the
playlist and then just kind of being
done with it but it is cool because this
comes in the aftermath of basically
carnage taking over Miles Morales now
remember carnage is going after
everybody who has an any former fashion
either come in contact with a with a
symbiote which grants them a codex
meaning that the symbiote leaves its DNA
behind or a person that he could add to
their rank add to his range in order to
basically bolster his abilities and use
them as a means to achieve his goal
right so it's really kind of two full
technically there wouldn't be a reason
for him to grab Miles Morales but Miles
Morales is a spider person and very
capable in his abilities and so using
him to his own to his own ends that
allows him to basically go against
spider-man and the rest of the
superheroes a little more well-armed
than he was before instead of just
relying on a huge amount of forces to
for him to use it as disposal now in
reality like for the most part in
comparison to earth superheroes numbers
Trump's powers almost all the time the
only exception you get with that or like
characters who can like warp reality or
who have powers that have a huge area of
effect right a huge AoE so like if
you're talking about somebody like storm
who can control like all the elements
well the numbers don't really matter
right because she's just like you get
lightning and you get lightning and you
get lightning everybody gets lightning
you know whereas it was someone like
Iceman he can just like freeze a ton of
people at one point but somebody like
Wolverine it's kind of like hack and
slash his way through each individual
person right so like you know numbers
for the most part will trump people with
huge amounts of abilities that's why
stories like this are always kind of
intriguing but Eddie Brock has to
essentially leave Miles Morales behind
right but this is kind of a funny thing
is because the simian sort of starts to
turn now this is what I love about
Donnie Cates handling of the Venom
symbiote right the fact that Donnie
kaise is sitting down and he's writing
the simian in a way towards its own
distinct character this is why I say I
think Donnie Cates run on venom will
turn out to be one of the greatest runs
on venom ever written right on because
you look
it's like okay so you get these these
cool progressions things like that but
the idea of Eddie Brock in the simian
fighting against each other in the sense
of the symbiote is just like we need to
kill as many of the forces of carnage as
we can and that includes Norman Osborn
and his response is no we can't kill him
because he's not under it's not under
his control right he's operating under
what what carnage wants him to do not
what is that he wants to do and the
response to venom is it doesn't matter
and that's kind of the I kind of saw it
with venom on this one right I mean I'm
curious which side you go with but I'm
honest I side with venom on this one
like sure he's not operating of his own
accord but it doesn't make him any less
dangerous right it doesn't make him want
to kill them any less right I mean he's
like his desire is to kill them like to
take them over and incorporate them into
into the the carnage symbiote and then
to kind of expand their numbers right
like knowing that he's not able to
operate under his own accord it doesn't
matter right like he still wants to take
them out so that's why it's kind of like
you know you do what you got to do right
people who win wars or ones willing to
do whatever it takes to win the war not
the ones who take the high ground right
so it's it's it's kind of cool right
like you got to fight fire with fire
the Allies against the Germans for
example right like both sides killed and
then we saw how that worked out so it's
it's a it's it's it's cool when it comes
to this because what is up happening
here is Eddie actually tries to turn his
back on the Venom symbiote for a minute
because the symbiote goes in and tries
to kill Norman Osborn and the responsive
Eddie is you can't like if you really
want to kill them fine go on ahead and
do it like I want to hit like I'm gonna
go save somebody like I'm gonna go be a
hero and this is interesting because
what it does is it hits the symbian in a
way to where it basically has this its
own moral struggle and that's what I
love about this is because the the
symbiote is now as much of a person as
Eddie Brock is right the symbiote center
spot works like okay yes like Norman
Osborn can't operate of its own accord
basically he's doing with the blood the
carnage symbiote tells him to you know
it's part of the the Grendel and all I
kind of cool stuff he's not operating of
his own will and yes he still wants to
kill us but it's killing him the right
thing to do and ultimately like venom
settles on the fact that he does it does
not believe it's the right thing to do
and in turn ends up rebonding to Eddie
grabbing a Mac Gargan grabbing scorpion
whose spine was broken by the forces of
carnage and then fleece basically takes
off and goes back to Russia Strickland's
safehouse which is of course again where
where Eddie Brock is operating out of
now again remember like when this whole
thing went down
basically Eddie Brock told spider-man to
get out of there and like to go find the
Avengers right to like
the Avengers together and so of course
that's exactly what spider-man did now
of course we get Wolverine and we get
Captain America to old school members of
the New Avengers when Brian Michael
Bendis wrote them we also end up getting
a Ben Grimm who again is a heavy hitter
and it's kind of what they need and then
we get the mind of Bruce Banner and the
reason why they need them or why they
need him is because when it comes to
human biology for the most part like you
do kind of have a hierarchy right I mean
you got Reed Richards valaria Richards
Doctor Doom at the top who trade like
the number one spot depending on who's
right in the story and then you kind of
start going down from there but just
because someone is like the third
smartest person in the world does not
mean their overall the third smartest
person read is the smartest person in
the world across the board that's true
but when it comes down to like
specializations like Bruce Banner takes
the cake when it comes to human biology
especially gamma radiation and so he's
the guy that kind of takes that takes
takes that stance when it comes to
technology
it's a Tony Stark I guess is these these
cool little things that you kind of see
where these specialization of characters
they can sort of lend themselves to
telling a particular type of story and
that's what's been going on here is that
the the science behind the maker in
terms of curing the son of venom of his
codex works right like the Codex is now
gone from the son of venom arms are gone
from another son event I'm gone from
from Norman from from the son of of
Norman Osborn and so basically I'm sorry
the grandson of Norman Osborn but it
works for that for the purpose that it
serves because what it means as this
technology can be used to basically cure
all the various superheroes of their
codices now what it does is it removes
one half of the reason why venom would
wear white corners would want to take
them right I mean if these various
characters have been hosted the Venom's
to me into some form or another and the
codices was left behind on them then in
turn like Connors would want to take
them in order to get that codex where
that codex being removed now carnage
doesn't have a reason at least as far as
that goes to take them but the power and
the knowledge of Captain America the
power of like Wolverine the power of Ben
Grimm would still serve as an asset
meaning carnage could still take them if
he chose so again like is there there's
still motivation there for him to
basically capture these guys and snatch
them up and run away and so as a result
of this you basically end up having you
know having these different guys kind of
thrown into these tubes of sorts then it
is on to basically remove this codex
from them now a really cool moment
happens here because when this takes
place spider-man walks up starts talking
to Eddie Brock and it's a really sort of
heart-to-heart conversation and this is
interesting because what it shows is
that there aren't really any hard
feelings between Peter and Eddie Brock
right and either there really weren't I
mean ultimately it was Eddie that kind
of came down to constantly tracking down
and constantly want to take out Peter ah
but at the end of the day it's one of
these things where they're basically
allies and this is why stories like this
are so cool it's because what it means
is that going forward Eddie Brock could
become and probably will be a tried and
true good guy right like I wouldn't be
surprised if you started seeing Eddie
Brock I'm more like Avengers stories
different things like that because of
how capable he is and because of the
fact that he's essentially turning over
a new leaf the issue with this is that
when Peter basically asked as Eddie are
you gonna tell Dylan about the fact that
you're basically his father that Eddie
for an instant seems to not know and
then Ponder's it and then in turn the
real Eddie comes running up out of
nowhere he's I do Peter get away from
that guy only for us to find out this is
not Eddie Brock this is carnage and it
is amazing I love these twists and turns
man I love what Donnie Cates is doing
with this new Donnie Cates man this guy
I swear to god man this this guy's like
right up here with Hickman for me like
the writing style is totally different
the ability to create epic stuff exactly
the same but it's it's amazing you're
Donnie Cates man everything this guy
writes is gold like it's it's oh my god
it's incredibly nuts I guess it's Donnie
Cates kudos to you man
I am diggin what I'm loving what you're
laying down man this this is awesome
because in turn like carnage basically
summons all of his forces in and starts
attacking every single one of these guys
and the response of venom is like look
like like I told you what would happen I
told you we had to take these guys out I
told you we had to kill them and I told
them what would happen if you were a
half-measure
if you didn't do what needed to be done
in order to win and that's ultimately
the coolest thing about this is this
like those who can't do what needs to be
done in order to win lose and that's
just the way it is it's always that way
right like you know it's it's it's it's
cool to take the moral high ground and
it makes you feel good at the end of the
day but at the end of the day you lose
and that's just the way it is so I guess
if you're okay with losing then the
moral high ground is fine if you're not
okay with losing then do what it takes
to win and that's the response to venom
if you're not willing to do what it
takes if you're not strong enough to do
what it takes then I will find someone
who
I will find someone who's strong enough
to be able to take this threat head-on
and not have any reservation about
killing the various forms of carnage
that are running around out there and so
in response to this the Venom symbiote
abandons Eddie Brock and bonds itself to
Bruce Banner following that like carnage
is kind of like I don't know who this
loser is whatever who cares let's focus
on the things need to be focused on but
instead he basically craps his pants
when he's when he comes face-to-face
with what I think is probably one of the
most cool characters that we've ever
seen in the history of comics venom Hulk
Wood that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace